I am still having trouble wrapping my
head around this oh he's just chilling
so hard we just discovered in secret
visual effect shot hey what's up welcome
to another episode of what happened to
the couch which clips
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to another
wonderful episode of visual effects
artist react this time we are back with
Bollywood Hollywood Hollywood there's a
million names for it we're calling it
bollywood because it sums it up nicely
I'm very excited for this Bollywood
episode because I mean honestly I truly
love Bollywood I love the passion behind
it all
when Bollywood is good it's like just
any American blockbuster but on like
total steroids because it's got this
crazy like over-the-top influence to it
and when it's bad it's kinda like a
really awesome high production quality
like Tim and Eric movie either way it
goes I love it
[Music]
[Applause]
dude I love how they just trying to kill
this guy they're like this prank of Marv
so high
[Applause]
you did it somehow got me more velocity
till I grab the handlebars commercial
yeah it's basically a Pepsi commercial
hardcore product placement so how did
they do it they just did it for real I
guess probably this looks like the most
classic Bollywood type of effect wire
removal wire removal
that's a intense shot so how do they so
how do they yeah good point
so if it's unknown at it the wires would
be I guess they definitely hide it
between the wires the camera he might be
on some sort of like hip thing he looks
like he's on a hip thing he'd even see
it in his shirt a little bit it looks
like he's not that high off the ground
and also the RAM disappeared and the
like pole vault thing disappeared
disappeared yeah basically
and maybe that bar is CG the bars
probably CG because the wires would have
clipped it yeah so there's like no
definition in that bar so yes like solid
or a red solid I'm colorblind
Oh how are you a VFX artist it's
sometimes it's hard you know
[Music]
wait a second all the signs are fake
yeah every single the affects is
probably the visual effects house that
night on this movie ocean so this movie
is about a guy who's got like
mythological ancestry and powers which
is why he's basically a superhero in the
modern day so when he's not doing sweet
jumps he's fighting bad guys yes
basically he got the bloodline of an
ancient swordsman - oh man look how
giddy here so and off this guy yeah yeah
wait who's this who's this his portly
buddy that was a sweet stunt there my
first reaction was like oh it's
miniatures and then it kind of doesn't
look like miniatures no it's like an
actual set with a green screen it looks
legit
I mean it could be it certainly could be
a miniature I think they just did it a
little bit yeah it looks like they just
took a thing like what threw it on a
ramp and it's just like a slingshot of
it well look at the the way the
helicopter actually moves after it's
being hit it flexes in a way in
miniature can't flex that fire coming
out of it like oh the Power Rangers
Power Rangers like
[Applause]
look out finally the jump is in that
angle it was a tiny jump oh yeah that's
real that's that's all really kind of a
sense so they're manually rotoscoping
that fire do you see that yeah oh my god
there's so many errors look at the mass
and then look at the feather on the
right side - what's the plan hotdog
freakin lazy
once again it's just the impact is the
transition point he's actually holding
on and you'll see right around there see
click ya in motion you don't see that
little glitch overall other than the
fact that the CG arm was kind of like a
hot dog yeah you know the actual
execution of doing that shot is really
good yeah agreed agreed oh and also
notice how he's actually specifically
turning so that his arm that just got
chopped is away from camera how do you
rotated the other way you'd have to use
effects to track in as stump yeah be a
lot harder to paint out the arm - no
absolutely it's easy to paint out an arm
this but once it's over your body if you
painted out now suddenly you have an arm
sighs the gap you have to now fill in
with custom elements speaking of arm
sized gaps actually got a clip you guys
to watch what is Segway
[Applause]
[Music]
I can tell you right now I know this
actor and he's a normal-sized guy so
this this is a movie about a low person
who is very well-off and they're trying
to find themselves he's actually 5/7 and
in the movie he's four eight the effects
in this movie are so flawless it hurts
my brain that's a full on camera move
like it was tracking backwards and also
painting to the right yeah
is this like Lord of the Rings stuff
well there's no because this it's it's
easy enough to do a camera move and have
you know regular-sized people and small
sized people they did that on Lord of
the Rings we broke that down in a
previous episode but they're holding
hands here that's what's blowing my mind
I am very confused
it doesn't it doesn't just hurt your
head dude yes let me let me break this
down for you guys so every shot in this
movie which had this actor shrunken down
to four eight they had to shoot five
takes for one take and they pieced
everything together in post when we did
Boston Dynamics that was probably like a
five six maybe seven step process this
is a 28 step process to get this guy to
look like a little person there so the
first take that they did was just the
actors walking together with the floor
removed all of their sets were kind of
like Legos so all the floors could be
moved around and and and taken out so
he's sunken down and he's holding hand
they're holding hands they're both in
the shot but they're still holding the
hand holding is real handling is real
okay the next take they do that actor on
the right doing his motion with no
people in the background no extras
holding his hand out without the main
actor the next take is a clean plate no
extras just just the background they do
another take extras only and then the
final take is the main actor holding an
invisible hand it's just him no extras
walking down holding his hand out
because speaking of arm size
yeah when you're painting something out
and you have a hand sized hole that you
need to replace you need that
information so the actor by himself is
the information that you would need to
shrink him down and fill in the gaps
with but that doesn't make sense though
like what but how is he like it's not
just him being shorter he's like scaled
ya know exact smaller and thinner so
looks like are they using for that I
think they're using all the takes and
different pieces of it so it's like
they're able to merge different parts of
each take together yes that's what it
seems like to me this has to be a motion
control system right yes they had some
pretty intense technology to shoot this
movie cuz if that was the case then that
crazy camera moved they do at the end
isn't all that crazy
yes it's repeatable so I guess that the
body double is like the reference yeah
look at that
okay the very next shot after this where
it's just like kind of a medium shot on
both of them except shrinking they still
shrink him like his shoulders aren't as
wide yeah his shoulders yeah there's
less distance between his shoulders see
that's the thing if it was just lower it
would look janky yeah exactly yes I see
what you're saying like this is some
tricky compositing yo you guys are you
guys really nuts do that hurts my head
like she's interacting with him I am
still having trouble wrapping my head
around this
I see the elements here but I can't tell
how they're piecing them together still
how do they look so naturally locked and
synced together I don't know if you guys
have any insight on sumzero
visual effects besides the one
behind-the-scenes video on the internet
please leave a comment below let us know
how this is done we got to crack the
case on this one man this one is intense
a lot of guys what you gonna do when
they come for you
when they come for you Oh watch out
we're good though cuz we got this guy oh
my god you see like the edge the edge
matt feather on the side put all
superheroes
yeah there's Lee Oh two BB's all
explosion bomb hill fire these
so I got a car coming at me no problem
just gonna stop it all right so this is
aambala 2015 one of my favorite
Bollywood action scenes here let's go
back to that Jeep jump this one actually
for once looked like it wasn't done in
the original shot oh dude so this is
like Photoshop yes nephew Photoshop
effects because the perspective doesn't
change as it goes from frame right to
frame left but they did put a reflection
on the van yeah like I was about to say
why are work for this stuff that now I'm
watching it it's like oh wow but stay
tuned because the very next shot
the very next shot is the wirework stuff
okay that's definitely us at least a
wire shot because the perspective of the
car is changing yeah yeah I feel bad for
the stunt man on the Jeep and that shot
look that impact he's just like snapshot
freeze frames are honestly the best part
about this and I can tell you how they
did them so they took the camera from
three different angles and the the onset
still photographer it wasn't like
alright photo shoot time dude those
matrix bullets their actual weight never
been touched by a human handling
perfectly perfectly pristine so this is
probably the VFX shot because they're
rolling out the ramps the cars are
hitting like it's a real explosion but
then the looks like the base of the
explosion is fake yeah cuz I think
they're like reworking it to paint out
the ramps
was he winking at the camera or the
ladies ladies go ladies I mean you can
see the ladies in his glasses oh you're
right you literally see the ladies in
the reflection of his and the reflection
is actually tracked on to the glasses
that's visual effects we just discovered
in secret visual effects shot yeah you
see how their the people are moving with
glass as opposed to like a joke but
you're totally right they literally
tracked the ladies into the reflection
see they should be in one spot and his
glasses revealed them and then when he
moves away they stay in place as it
wipes away but in the shot here the
ladies actually move with his glasses
it's like he has bifocal means he has
eyes only for these ladies no matter
where he looked yes yes it's yeah ladies
yes I had no idea until just I don't
think I think I think it's a detail of
the shot but no one noticed Ambala
Ambala Bravo
yes Bravo if you guys have any sort of
Bollywood scenes that feature a dude
cooler than this I will not believe you
but maybe leave it in the comments down
below
hey guys Jake here you might know me as
the producer around here and well I am
here to talk to you about today's
sponsor ray con I wanted to speak to you
honestly today because most people don't
understand exactly how hard it is for me
to do my job here for example I'm
supposed to be telling you about these
earbuds and all I really want to do is
go get a glass of water unfortunately
for me I can't go out there because it's
like a Bollywood action scene people are
jumping all over each other there's
bullets flying everywhere
normally that would drive me insane the
courtesy to these little earbuds right
here when I put them in it's like I'm
the only one in the room let me show you
what I mean
[Music]
the first thing you need to know about
Ray Con earbuds is that they start at
about half the price of any other
premium wireless earbud on the market
and guess what they sound just as
amazing that's right there twenty five
is one of their best models yet with
over six hours of play time seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass and a
beautiful compact design with a nice
noise isolating fit they also come in
new fun colors now I don't know about
you but if you're interested in finding
an obtaining inner peace consider
clicking the link in the description
below and you'll get 15% off your first
order thanks for watching feel free to
subscribe because we got some cool stuff
coming out next week we experiment with
long exposure photography and drones and
if you missed it there's a whole
adventure about me trying to learn how
to fly a jet suit watch this video right
here it's in the past right there it's
over there it's over there and I hope to
see you next week so subscribe
[Music]